come to GameSpot's continuing coverage
of e3 2014 you're watching the Samsung
stage I'm your host Daniel Dwyer it's my
last appointment of the day I gotta say
it's one of the most exciting ones
codenamed steam was announced yesterday
and I'm very happy to be joined by Paul
of intelligent systems how you doin sir
nice to meet you thank you so much for
coming on the stage today thank you for
having us and allowing us to present our
game to everyone not at all i usually
get my list of games weeks in advance
and I pile through them and i'm i gonna
have to go to another go and then
eventually there's unannounced nintendo
game ace and I'm like okay when am I
gonna know what this is and it wasn't
until last night that you guys actually
revealed it to the price yeah well how
was that well I've been told it went
very well I was very nervous but yeah I
think I hope that people got a good
understanding of you know the core
mechanics and what we attempted to do
with the game and where we wanted to go
in terms of you know the artistic
ambitions and also the the goals that we
set for this game yes well you guys you
know advanced wars and fire album and
intelligent systems are are known for
those high quality experiences that sort
of real good tactical stuff in fact it
could be said that what people would
have been really happy if you just
enhance the sequel to any one of those
games and so why the why did you why a
new IP why white hello this was a
decision from mystery amagami our
producer who thought it would be well
for one thing so he had so much faith in
this in our original pitch hmm that he
thought you know this would work as a
new IP and he also thought that if it's
it is different enough that we shouldn't
so we already have what those series do
is what those series yeah they're very
sort of turns down they should keep
doing it so if we have a new idea it
would be a waste to just like call it
or something something or four of them
something something when it's obviously
not that sure yeah so well it is risky
to to have a new ID I think it's the
right decision to launch it like that
and not kind of rely on on a name or
marketing budget or something and so you
Paul you've actually brought this
gameplay to us it's a game is only
announced yesterday and this is the
first time we're actually having a look
at at it being played live so can you
just explain the moment-to-moment action
what's happening here in code names team
so code names tim is a turn-based
strategy game but it is played entirely
from a third-person perspective hmm so
almost like like a shooter game and the
system that we use may be familiar to
player like especially the original XCOM
or perhaps I myself I grew up on a spec
ii back in Romania and we had a force
laser squad yes of course a so it uses
an an action point system therefore you
don't have that style so environment
events was we have that very structured
style of move attack but select the next
move select the next unit move and
attacks like the next unit move and
attack but for this game because it
takes place on a on a 3d battlefield and
we don't give you an overview map like
it's entirely played from this
perspective you don't get any other
helpers that style of gameplay simply
didn't work so we went for for action
points and we represent the dejection
points as steam so it's a steampunk team
game it takes place in a in an alternate
19th century and this is a special team
of very gifted individuals put together
by American President Abraham Lincoln
excellent fight these very strange
aliens that you see there it's good that
there's lots of well as many of these
games but people are familiar with with
sort of the the line of sight that's on
player itself like frozen synapse
and like you said XCOM even the new XCOM
but those games are predominantly plays
isometrically yes and what is it that
from the third person perspective and
that sort of makes it makes it different
well uh it brings I like to say that it
brings an element of actual depth to the
hayride like like visual don't like
visual there yes so what happens is that
you are limited so each unit is limited
to a very narrow Camaro of the
battlefield so but since you control
multiple units a big part of this game
is sculpting your environment with the
various units and from these various
viewpoints try to build up a a view of
the battlefields in your head and then
based on that build the plan for action
and we discovered so me personally I
really pushed for having a 2d map or
having a compass or something like just
give me some kind of feedback but uh
mystery amagami our producer and the
people from Nintendo were very adamant
that this this first-person view is so
compelling and it's so it's bring
something very fresh to the genre than
ashes really we should really stick to
it it's an interesting argument to make
on either side because perhaps the most
important part of any turn-based game or
what we're used to at least is the map
is knowing how far you are from so even
if you don't know what's over there you
know that only a certain amount of
things could be over there you know it's
even a little bit of information means
so much and so I guess in that respect
how how do you have you set up for
attacks if you're not really sure what's
around the next corner well of course in
this game you can use overwatch so you
can leave some steam over so the action
points as i said its steam you can leave
some steam left over for the next turn
oh crap and wait for enemy to come
around the corner there sometimes smart
enough not to do that but in order to
make the game fun for the player we
we've also added the enemies that would
that would attack you and they would get
caught into the overwatch and actually
since we are on the subject of overwatch
you know we really worked hard to make
the overwatch mechanic different and
fresh so we've added several features
that I feel are perhaps unique to this
game and one of them is the fact that
well of course doing an overwatch attack
means that you can damage the enemy on
their turn yes but it can also stand
them okay so because many of the enemies
are quite tough you you won't be able to
kill them it's it's quite common that
you wouldn't be able to kill them in
your media Renteria so what you can do
is you can take a gamble on on your
weapons ability to stand an enemy which
is different from weapons weapons and
there are some characters that have
weapons that are better at doing this so
you take a gamble on the overwatch and
you use the overwatch to prevent the
enemy from doing anything else on their
turn so you negate their movement on
their turn and then you get to finish
the job on the next excellent how long
or is each level because you can sort of
lean into this you know you can you can
scale this quite quite typical lots of
tactical games can be quite long on a
portable system sometimes you want to
keep it keep it short so how do you guys
kind of way that up very perceptive of
used to say that because it's a portable
game we want to need to keep it somewhat
short and we what we also wanted to have
variety so the maps are fairly so
they're not ridiculously large yeah I
mean we have some very large maps
but the majority of the maps are of a
lens that would allow you to kind of
finish them you know in a matter of well
less than an hour definitely but you
know you know you know it dozens of
minutes like 20 minutes 30 minutes can
you can consume admission saves yeah of
course on Carrie perfect and what we did
is that initially we had like really big
levels that would take mp3 long time 22
and it was kind of like it wasn't boring
you know I mean it was the same game but
you know when you have a map like you
have the the design goals for that map
you you you are limited to the the
amount of variation can have within the
same map yes of course so what we
decided to do is actually to have
missions structures over several maps so
you have several smaller maps but that
play quite differently and so you get
you all the time you get to see
something new or have a new gameplay
experience fairly often in this game I
mean I would like to think you do and
this is again something that I feel
perhaps not so many strategy games
managed to do like yeah in many strategy
games kinda end up doing the same thing
over and over again and it was important
to try to avoid this and I'm gonna take
couple of questions well Paul Zoe
Richmond's asking at the characters in
this game as so how many characters do
you have them do they have individual
traits yes I'm not going to tell you the
total number of characters it's quite a
few of them there's not a ridiculous
number of them because we wanted each
character to have a personality and to
feel really unique their individual
traits are their main weapon so they
each have a main weapon that is very
different like they have very
specialized and sometimes very strange
functions like some of them you will
need to use your imagination in order to
figure out a way to use it their second
characteristic is the fact that they
have a special move I think you may have
seen several of them like a special
spectacular attack in
which again is very useful but you'll
have to learn how to use it like you can
you can waste it very easily you can
only use those ones for map okay like
they don't consume any any resource but
you can only use the ones and how many
characters you tell is it for permission
yes it is a a four-man team excellences
and I love how it's actually even coming
up alien movement in between the the
movement pieces that give me a very x
call me feel as well in terms of them I
guess the campaign is a work and how
long is that is that is it you heavily
do you sort of lean into the skirmish
mode March or is it mostly got to do
with a single story thread in this case
we went with a story based so you really
wanted to create this again have variety
and have this most kind of structure
filled to the game player so we do not
have a skirmish mode there's a the
campaign is is set up so that it's a
linear campaign so you progress from
mission to Mission and hopefully like
there's a lot of variety and new things
that you see and do your over like over
the course of the mission I think for an
average player it would take a fairly
long time I mean I don't know like I
think I never to be honest with you I so
confident I'm yeah but I it is it is a
long campaign I'm assuming you guys yeah
if you look at the the total number of
missions it may seem is not so much yeah
but once you get into it anyway to
actually discover that it's it's quite a
minigame there's quite a lot of
conferences here I'm assuming you don't
have any multiplayer aspect of it at all
you're assuming wrong I am tell me about
it I cannot tell you so well all we can
reveal at this point is that there are
multiplayer mode both locally and online
but we will roll out those a bit you
know
yeah in the future I bony the games
aren't even enhanced one day yes so I
which by the way good job because there
was a trademark filing about two months
ago yeah meconium seem and nobody put
two and two together yeah I was very
glad about it because that was pretty
much the last two months I was like oh
my god oh my god like when will they
figure it out but nobody did there you
go that was excellent yo we got a scoop
as well here on the game spot stages are
very happy with okay so this isn't
coming in until 2015 and do you guys
think it'll be close to the start of the
year middle end that is not my decision
so I don't know fair enough okay let's
talk about some of the mechanics then
specifically as well so getting a lot of
questions at based on that a line of
sight is there a distance limiter on
line of sight can you hit is there a fog
of war happening or can you hit as long
as you can see somebody no there is no
fog aboard so you can you can see as far
as your i kin sinker but there is a
range to the weapons so you will be able
to see enemies that you cannot shoot so
this will allow you to plan so we
actually so I I did it did have a fog of
war for a long time but we discovered it
was it was not having an overview map
yes it was quite difficult to play
disorientation yes so and it was also
very difficult to explain I mean you
just kind of moved forward and then
suddenly an enemy would pop out of
nowhere like he just looked unnatural
yes it was a hard decision for me
because I felt that the there should
have been like a line of sight like me
but but it just didn't feel right so we
gave you the ability so you can see as
far as you can see and actually on this
point mmm a lot of our maps perhaps not
this one this one not so much but some
actually this one this particular map
has a lot of underground but Jillian's a
personal plane didn't take that that's
rough our maps have a lot of verticality
to them I can see you can see even with
the weapons in terms of the mortar as
well and so it becomes very important in
this game to take the high ground
because the high ground will give you a
better view of the battlefield so
just finding those places and getting in
disguise play in his high place is a
very important part of the strategy and
so the story it's out then is this an
alien invasion happening in an alternate
late 19th century artists okay and you
can see like i'm going to give you this
much this is a some applicants ease is
setting in a graveyard it's a bit of a
spooky atmosphere so our enemies and and
perhaps part of the main story of the
game is inspired by the works of HP
Lovecraft cool I want to ask you one
more question as well sue and the child
is asking and what's the deal with when
your players die is there a dead state
is a revived stage that you can get them
into and in terms of like all the
characters you have can you lose
characters that you can't ever get back
again no this is a so because in this
game you don't have a lot of abstract
parameters and stuff that you level up
for the characters you actually have to
think of your team as a team yep so all
of your characters are important and you
have to combine them for each maps
you'll have to find the best loadout and
the best characters for each map so
because of this if we had something like
permit that you wouldn't be able to
progress in the chem course yeah it
would hurt you so much further on yes so
there is no such mechanic like your
units will will revive between maps and
you also you will also have mechanisms
to revive them on the map excellence
both intelligent systems thank you so
much for coming on at this time some
states forums com I thank you for giving
us this opportunity and I'm looking
forward to I know in the future give up
oh yeah absolutely our code names team
is a game that we didn't know about 24
hours ago and it's great to have you on
the stage and talk about it really
appreciate you very much that's my time
on the Samsung stage done and dusted
I'll be appearing on the game spot stage
later on and with some hot ribs black
gold online and pretty sure I've talked
to them every single III and plants vs
zombies garden warfare which course it's
coming to next-gen system PlayStation 4
so yeah i'll be over there in about two
hours time the show continues there's so
many games i'm show floor so many